>> WE HAVE SEEN THE INVOLVEMENT
OF THIS WHOLE PERFORMATIVE KIND
OF POLITICS.
FROM SARAH PALIN TO WHAT WE HAVE
NOW.
>> TERI LEIKER -- SEEM LIKE SHE
HAS THE CHAMPION ABILITY.
>> SORT OF PERFORMATIVE
REPRESENTATION RATHER THAN
ACTUAL REPRESENTATION.
I SUSPECTED THAT IS WHAT THEY
WILL GET WITH TERI LEIKER.
>> Laura: IT IS IRONIC THAT THEY
ACCUSED HER OF PERFORMATIVE
MULTICS WHEN THAT IS ALL THEY
HAVE.
THEY ARE PART OF THE LEFT'S
EMPTY PROMISES, THE WOKE
IDENTITY MULTICS AND SO IS TULSI
GABBARD.
SHE ANNOUNCED SHE IS LEAVING THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND TONIGHT SHE
IS ENDORSING ARIZONA'S
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE TERRY LAKE.
NEWLY DECLARED INDEPENDENT TULSI
GABBARD JOINS US LIVE FROM AN
EVENT FOR KARI LAKE.
TELL ME ABOUT TONIGHT AND WHAT
DROVE YOU TO ENDORSE KARI LAKE
TONIGHT?
>> Congresswoman Gabbard: I'M
HERE IN PHOENIX JOINING HUNDREDS
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME OUT IN
SUPPORT OF KARI LAKE TONIGHT.
THERE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A
DEBATE BUT HER OPPONENT IS
REFUSING TO DEBATE HER AND STAND
TOE TO TOE WITH HER.
I THINK THIS IS REALLY
INDICATIVE OF THE NATIONAL
PROBLEM THAT WE ARE SEEING WITH
THE CURRENT DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
RATHER THAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
DEBATE IN THE MARKET PLACE OF
THEM DIED THOSE IDEAS WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, WHERE PEOPLE
CONNECTION TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION TO EITHER REFUSE TO BE
A PART OF THE CONVERSATION OR
THEY THROW OUT ALLIES AND SMEARS
AND ATTACKS SEEKING TO UNDERMINE
THE CREDIBILITY OF ANYONE WHO
DARES TO CHALLENGE THEIR
NARRATIVE AND THIS IS THE SORT
OF THINK THAT LEAD ME TO LEAVE
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY BECAUSE IN MY
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO THE POLICIES
AND ACTIONS WE ARE SEEING COMING
OUT OF THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
THIS SO-CALLED WOKE FANATICAL
IDEOLOGICAL IS THEY ARE AGAINST
FREE SPEECH.
ARROGANCE DEMOCRACY.
ARROGANCE FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
THEY ARE AGAINST THE VERY
PRINCIPLES OF THIS COUNTRY, OUR
GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS ENSHRINED IN
OUR CONSTITUTION.
AND MEANWHILE THEY ARE PUSHING
US FURTHER AND FURTHER TOWARDS
THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR WORK THAT
THREATENS THE VERY EXISTENCE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
WORLD.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GET INTO IN
DETAIL HERE BUT ULTIMATELY
CONTENT -- IT COMES DOWN TO
PEOPLE AND POWER WHO DON'T
BELIEVE IT AND ACTIVELY
UNDERMINING THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLES OF THIS COUNTRY AND
IS NOT SOMETHING THAT I CAN BE
ALIGNED WITH.
>> Laura: KATIE HOBBS WAS ON CNN
AND THIS WAS A REALLY TELLING
MOMENT FOR HER.
WATCH.
>> KARI LAKE HAS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT SHE IS NOT INTERESTED IN
HAVING SUBSTANTIVE IN THE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER TO ARIZONANS.
SHE ONLY WANTS A SCENARIO WHERE
SHE CAN CONTROL THE DIALOGUE.
THERE IS A LOT MORE ABILITY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
WITHOUT HER INTERRUPTIONS AND
SHOUTING.
SHE IS ONLY INTERESTED IN
CREATING A SPECTACLE.
>> Laura: TULSI, THAT IS THEIR
LINGO, WHICH IN THIS CASE JUST
MEANS BEING A BETTER POLITICIAN.
>> Congresswoman Gabbard: IT IS
ABOUT WHAT YOU ARE COMMUNICATING
TO THE PEOPLE.
IT IS THE SAME THING THAT I
SHARED WITH MY CONSTITUENTS.
SHE IS GOING TO THE MOST
RIGOROUS JOB INTERVIEW PROCESS,
LETTING THE PEOPLE OF ARIZONA
NO, I AM HERE APPLYING FOR A
JOB.
YOU ARE MY BOSS.
NOT SOME CORPORATE SPECIAL
INTEREST.
NOT SOME BIG PARTISAN PARTY BUS.
SHE HAS MADE IT CLEAR THAT HER
ACCOUNTABILITY IS TO THE PEOPLE
OF ARIZONA AND SHE HAS LAID OUT
A VERY BROAD AND THOROUGHLY
THOUGHT OUT PLATFORM AND WHAT
SHE PLANS TO DO AS GOVERNOR.
SHOULD THEY ELECT HER.
>> Laura: KELSEY, I CANNOT WAIT
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN ARIZONA.
IT HAS BEEN THROUGH A HELLUVA
LO